[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this
weekend what this week at the round
table of dim lighting I thought we might
be in the uh you know this week in the
table but it's this week at the table
I'm just thinking about this weekend man
we got quite a weekend
planned um this week at the round table
of demm lighting I'm going to tell you
something that's going to blow your mind
regarding
interstates okay unless you happen to
already know this well that made a
little bit of snot come out my nose and
we're going to cover at least it wasn't
as bad as the mashed potatoes that you
and gravy that you got on your overalls
well that's why I got a moment ago
that's why I got my my my bibs on what
are we are we dealing with things oh no
no I just meant if you needed a tissue
oh tissues no I don't need I don't need
a tissue okay just cuz I got snot coming
out of my nose and mashed potatoes on my
work wear bib well you know what that's
what it's there that's the purpose of it
and that's why they're white y so
they'll show all the stains that you get
on them apparently there's some gravy on
my my
ters um I I I want to talk a little bit
about
um some fashion aspirations that I got
not related to wearing aspirations these
white overalls but I'll get to that
later aspirations I can't wait to hear
about Interstate mindblowing unrealized
aspirations yes you need to slow down
man yes there's
something there's something that I want
so bad and I just don't know how to get
it and I'm so jealous of the people who
have
it okay uh one thing I would like to do
quickly is just re I don't want to
revisit our quickie conversation which
turned into an argument pretty quickly
the last time we were together on this
podcast you don't want to revisit it uh
I just want to I don't want to revisit
the argument okay I just want to uh give
you I just happened to in light of our
conversation worms in light of our
conversation I was just like I'm curious
right because again just to to not to
resurface the argument but to we began
talking about the aspect of quickies and
I think I mistakenly started by asking
link how long he thought a quickie was
at which he said 13 minutes which I said
what are you trying to prove and then
and and the truth of the matter is I
wasn't trying to prove anything um yeah
and I and you know what I believe that
is true uh but inevitably by by starting
the conversation with you thinking that
a quakey was 13 minutes I was left on no
man's land as is demonstrated in the way
the conversation was interpreted however
I now have some scientific information I
would like to throw your away I don't I
so so you're bringing this back up again
no in order to no I'm bringing back up
because say that like to prove that I
was wrong I don't I just don't
understand no no okay okay what's your
motive my motive is that I was genuinely
interested in what is the average length
of penetrative vaginal sex okay and has
there been any research that has done
been done on this yeah okay and so now
because I was on the record by the end
of the episode of saying that like I
don't I don't even we weren't even
talking about the we weren't talking
about the same thing exactly I was
talking about a quickie
right and I wasn't weren I was talking
about a quick sexual session right
different thing different thing I was
and so when I was talking about a
quickie I was actually talking about a
quickie and so then I was like okay so
what do what does the
inter oh no okay see so now I am going
to get defensive because are you not
genuinely interested okay so all right
how long do you think what do you think
the average for vaginal penetrated of
sex is and this is a okay so there's two
studies that have been done okay but
there was one where they basically gave
uh like 500 couples stopwatch and said
we want you for a month to act to to
begin having sex and we and I'm talking
about the moment of penetration to
ejaculation okay get started it's not
setember right my answer is going to be
13 minutes no matter what cuz I feel
like now I got to die on this hill for
some reason well no but 13 minutes
whatever makes you happy 30 seconds so
no and according on your chronological
time scale which is redundant 13 minutes
was your quick version just so we just
so understand that's why I said what are
you trying to
prove would you believe me I just want
to go and say I am never trying to prove
anything that's
evident how long do you think is the
you're not interested in this do you no
I'm okay yeah thous couples surveyed
themselves just in and
outs how long
um why are you doing this to me again
you're asking me to give a number I
can't do this I don't do this I don't
measure things I don't I don't do
numbers okay but it might be interesting
it just might be
interesting
um 90 seconds does that make you happy
well you think the average is 90 seconds
I don't I my brain does not work in this
way dude well you have a guess like I
just gave it to you 90 seconds well no
it's not 90 seconds um the average for
vaginal sex was 3 to seven minutes
coming out at an actual average of
about the second study it was five and a
half minutes was like the thing that
they actually landed at was the average
okay okay now so I so just to kind of
give you when I was thinking quickie
what I was thinking was
again and and then I looked up to make
sure that I'm just not crazy and so the
sort of the generally accepted
definition of a quickie is penetrative
sex that happens without foreplay
usually it's just a quick sexual
encounter and almost always given the
nature of the time frame it is only the
male who experiences orgasm which as I
explained last time inherently a selfish
thing on the part of a man that's why it
is a very small part of the sexual pie
pie so to speak okay for me
okay but speaking of 13 minutes I
thought that you might be encouraged to
know uh that the average time to achieve
orgasm uh for a woman is 13 and a half
minutes so there you go
Technically when you stop 30 seconds
short no that's your wife having an
orgasm it is uh is I guess it
technically a quickie for you and but
what I'm telling you that's my answer
was that the quickest that we could both
yeah yeah right right which is not the
definition of a quickie just you know
colloquial speak speaking or
scientifically speak you know what
you're so right I'm so glad you brought
this up again I haven't thought about it
once since we talked about it but hold
on but what I'm just not once this is
not interesting to
you I'm so interested I'm just saying I
I'm not invested in it personally right
but you've been Vindicated that 13
minute sexual session if you're both
interested in achieving orgasm is almost
long enough to actually achieve that uh
that's and that's exactly what I was
talking about so if in Link's World well
Link's definition of a quickie which I
would we'll just call it linkx quickie
okay which also would be a great fast
food let's just call it a quick one I
think that's what we call it can we get
a quick one we okay can we get a quick
both people achieve orgasm if you get to
13 minutes you're getting close to that
but if you're going with a traditional
selfish quickie we're really saying five
and a half minutes you've got to be
quicker than five and a half minutes
because five and a half minutes is the
average length of penetrative sex up to
orgasm so so you're actually trying to
to I'm not trying to say anything I
think that's the interesting thing I'm
trying to communicate the facts you're
attaching
motivation I'm not saying why why I'm
motivated to do it you're attaching
motivation to why I'm trying to do it I
so when a scientist goes out when a
scientist goes out and does an
experiment and comes back with his
results is your first
question what are you trying to say man
why are you bringing this up up well I'm
bringing up because it's interesting
what can people learn from
Facts I'm glad he did so if you're
lasting five and a half minutes and I
think what they were doing is they were
inserting and then thrusting continually
good until orgasm which is not
recommended you know you want to you
don't you want to do other things but so
technically a quickie would be anything
less than average probably on the lower
end of that because in the survey what
they found is that lasted from a range
do you know what the lowest was the
lowest
recorded well I read the article I just
can't remember 33 seconds so that's what
I call G gorilla mode okay we've
established that that's what I call
Gorilla mode they didn't call it gorilla
mode in the article in the study and
maybe they will the next time they come
out with
it so gorilla mode is about 33 seconds
which I like I said it's not easy but
under certain circum irst ances is if
I'm potentially being attacked if I'm
protecting resources that kind of thing
I might be able to go gorilla mode and
pull that off and the high end of
potentially being attacked the high end
of the average is 44 minutes so that
might be somebody in your family uh you
know if so because you're a 13-minute
quicky man even though you did then say
that snail mode then you didn't I guess
somebody was able to continually thrust
for like two episodes of the
Kardashians you know well they weren't
watching the Kardashians
cuz I just think this is half hour show
I think they're attractive is it a half
hour
show uh I think it's I think it's in the
40 I think it's an hour show two
episodes of
Seinfeld just to be clear 22-minute show
soon I thought I thought I'd bring that
up for
science I'm glad you did man I'm glad
you did I don't want to go gorilla mode
on you so if you have Quicky cuz gorilla
mode can mean other things too it
doesn't just mean quick sex it also
means beating your chest and then
beating the hell out of somebody which I
don't I'm not going to do that because
I'm you know they're vegetarians they
actually they look very menacing but
they never arm they don't arm us all
they're also endangered it's serious
issue so how do you feel interstat how
do you feel about being enlightened no
no I I want I want save interace I
really that's that's really what gets me
horny uh I've got I've got a story you
should have you should have lued me up
with an interstate mindblowing oh well
I've got a story you went back to I've
got a story about something that
happened to me and then I've got
Interstate facts I feel like I need to
hear something from you before I get
into any of that oh okay so you want to
know about my fashion stuff uh right
after we let everyone know a couple of
things uh we're still in the midst of my
birthday sale last a week Zone I think
from the 10th through the
18th we are uh I am giving 10% off all
first deegree plans and 20% off all
second and third degree plans to the
mythical
Society I'm going Guerilla mode on
giving away discounts you have 30
seconds to join uh no you have until the
18th of October to join take advantage
come on take advantage get in there on a
mythical Society lots of interesting
things in fact something that we shot
last night which is why my eyes are so
red because we were just
like it was exciting we were screaming
so scared we were so scared we may have
announced it by now by the time this
comes out I don't know but something
very very worth your while that we did
with Stevie and I'm sore that made us
I'm sore too neck oh yeah Stevie heard
her neck just while we were doing it
yeah
the jerking it's all the jerking if that
if that tempts you also mythical
society.com while it's my birthday week
I'm going to take uh advantage of this
opportunity to remind you that the
second single from my upcoming EP I make
music under a moniker James and the
shame I I wrote a song about my wife
it's called Uh the one I love to find it
came out on
Friday you can go listen to it but
also I have made the physical album
available for pre-order so the vinyl the
cassette and the CD you can go ahead and
pre-order the entire EP all six songs
unfortunately you are going to have to
wait until release day to hear all of
the songs but you will get a digital
download of the songs this time
something I didn't do last time but
people requested it so I'm like hey you
going to do that um so you can pre-order
that you so you get the album you buy
the album and you get the digital
download yeah and then when it hits
streaming right and then when the
different physical aspects are ready the
vinyl will take the longest just because
of supply chain uh but they they'll come
to you when they're ready and there's
also some some merch associated with
this whole EP that's available so James
andth shame. comom which just
automatically redirects to James andth
sham store.com but you don't need to
know that okay so if you wanted to know
it thank you for supporting heard that
the music uh and I'm gonna I am
signing some up to a certain amount and
then I stop but I'll let you know when
I'm doing that I may have already I
don't know I don't think so no I haven't
stopped signing
yet your biscus is brought to you by
better help you know sometimes you know
the right thing to do but you just don't
know if you have the strength to do it
that's like a paraphrase of a quote
that's a meme forget about it right
anyway um I'm thinking about like having
an interpersonal conflict I'm not going
to give any specifics but I know how to
take the high road but I just don't I
just I'm not ready to take it but
therapy has helped me get there well
that's because therapy helps you figure
out what's holding you back so you can
work for yourself instead of against
yourself we love therapy we're huge
advocates for it so you know that we're
all about making it as accessible as
possible so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give Better Health a
try it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge make
your brain your friend with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com
today to get 10% off your first month
that's
betterhelp.com
okay let's hear about your fashion
aspirations
I I mean how much stuff do you buy
through Instagram
ads um like I'm just trying to quite
quite a bit like I've I think I've said
this before I'm on record I think saying
that I A lot of times I'll go on
Instagram when I feel like
shopping and I'll just scroll through
the crap that normally I would be on
Instagram to see which is mostly like
Camper vans driving through national
parks I think that's what my Instagram
is mostly and then like and then
Genius lyrics I think this is what my
Instagram is Genius lyrics genius.com
genius.com okay
um and then yes a couple of mythical
things show up but I'm really just going
past all that to get to the next ad cuz
it's pretty good at showing me stuff
that I think I want to buy it's pretty
well talked targeted
um I will say I keep getting ads
for um like legitimately two or three a
day from that company that you have all
the stuff from and I feel like I can't
buy anything from that company because
it's oh the the clothing imperfect imp
perfect I'm like I can't do I mean yeah
this is actually from I'm like I can't
get this stuff from here because I I
pretty much own like right 80% of what
they make but I don't know how to tell
them to stop now you don't you do Todd
Snider cuz I'm kind of I've done some
Todd Snider but it's a little too dressy
for me I I found that Todd Snider it's
to me the fit is so important that I'm
getting a lot of Todd SN things the
tallboy but there is a lot of stuff
that's just I ain't gonna pay that much
for a freaking shirt that looks like a
coat yeah it's and it's pretty it's a
little too New York for me but I love it
on you now okay I'mma give you know what
I went through that wave it's not for me
anymore I think it fits you okay now so
okay
again you throw these little barbs man I
throw the barbs you throw you throw a
lot of barbs on the other thing you get
away with it because you wear overalls
and you're cute but I just want you to
know that you throw a lot of barbs but
you get away with it we have to run
interference on who Our Brands are and
I'm just saying I bought some stuff from
Todd Snider and
now I'm it's it's not exactly I feel
like it's more you than me okay and
just it doesn't have any anything to do
with any sort of wave or being ahead or
behind anything right but this is
probably when I need to announce my new
line gorilla mode you can dress up
listen this is this is a sincere this is
what's really behind this I think you
can you can dress up more than me and it
works for you like if I I feel if I
dress
up I start to get self-conscious I'm a
little boyish now and I'm sitting here
wearing wearing some overalls today
careful now you know I do have this
boyish chip on my shoulder well I think
it's a combin a button a button up with
glasses yeah there's something to it
could be a little to it could be a
little too buttoned up and Todd Snider
is more dressy that's and it's so I
think that it fits you you know it's
like you got the you got the rugged
beard and all the shaggy hair and it
balances out I don't look like I'm
walking into a business meeting at any
time right even if you're wearing that
stuff right right but like a dressy
lumberjack feel like I've I can't do
that so I am envious of that so maybe
that's where the Barb came from I'll own
that barb okay Barb um but yeah I'll
still get their
ads I got some ads for some
shoes and you know shoes these days the
souls are getting so big and I'm like I
do
I and then I'm like I don't I don't
think I don't think I'm going to get on
this train and then you you see so many
Souls you're like what they do they look
they look so comfortable they really do
I'm going to get some of these I wish I
had them on today I forgot I was going
to talk about this I warm this well I'll
get to this so I saw these shoes I'm not
even going to say the brand and uh I'm
like I'mma get yeah I'm going get these
things and it's just so much easier to
shop first of all cuz right there on
Instagram you're just like sliding and
then if you you know left right whatever
make it super easy so easy you're right
it's so easy it's it's too easy it's too
easy well shopping is is just the bane
of my existence I going into like I
don't I just cannot I just can't do it
oh God it's so it's like torture it's
it's like bloodletting you know it's
like everyone on the outside thinks it's
good for you but then when it happens to
you it kills you like it look I can feel
the the energy draining from my body
when I'm walking through a store and
everything fits me I'm not like you
where it actually sucks to shop yeah I
don't know actually I don't know why you
don't like it because the thing I don't
like about it is I if I take 10 things
into the changing room one fits if I'm
lucky I listen I'm sorry dude can I
touch your shoulder and you have to like
put it on and butt there's a lot stuff
and I'm buttoning up you know I'm
buttoning cuz you got to you got to do a
couple of buttons at least to get it to
close how many more buttons do you even
have to button than the average person
probably one oh there probably just one
extra one might be two I think they
actually just spread out I don't really
know I've never thought about button
counting yeah I do think they probably
cuz then
proportionally you know you be like
actually I think you can no I think it
may be a new button because if buttons
are too far from each other he's gaping
then you see into people's shirt yep you
don't want to see a gaped
nipple you'd have nipple gape I'm not
really that concerned about it but it
just it's not very
becoming I saw these shoes I'm like man
they look comfortable and I don't have
any black sneakers that really work for
me and I you know what I'm going to get
these oh the black- on black I saw that
you had uh the soles are brown oh but
they're all dark the whole the whole
shoe is dark whole shoe is dark which
I've always interpreted as a dorky
shoe um and that's probably that's
probably you know that's probably my
issue yeah maybe yeah I maybe it is
because yeah I was
thinking I don't know if this looks cool
so maybe that's what makes it cool makes
it cool trust me I'm yeah I got several
things I do think these things I've got
several things now that I'm like I don't
like actually objectively subjectively
like these clothes but I think that
they're in style yeah and that's no way
to live but we do it well you kind of
have to if you want to seem like you're
not a middle-aged man I wanted to I want
it to look kind of fashion forward but
it's got to it's got to feel good to
wear you know it's got to it's got to
lay right on your body or around your
foot and I get these things
and the damn toe is all narrow and I'm
like oh my my my toes are being smooshed
these are not comfortable I bought them
cuz I thought they were they were they
looked so comfortable so smooshy you
know it's not a Hoka but it's like a
ripoff Instagram Hoka kind of okay okay
H
okay and the way that they're made like
it's almost like there's a sock inside
of it all these tennis shoes now there's
like a it's like the inside is not is
there's a whole neopren type sock thing
happening under there but this seems
like it might be a good idea though it
seems like a good idea you don't seem
happy about it and I'm like well they
squish my to so I got to return them
just narrow toe and I tried to return
like you bought these on sale you can't
you can't we want you can't return them
and I just and I was like well
well is that how it works you can't
return it probably said like no returns
it probably said no returns yeah it's I
guess you were so good at shopping and
so fast that you missed it so then I'm
like you know what I'm going to make
this work I do like how they look
they're growing on me cut your foot I'm
going to wear these shoes without a sock
because there's a neoprene sock inside
of the shoe anyway and how's that going
to make your toes fit well there's less
room taking up by a sock how big are
your socks well there's every little bit
helps man I can't return them okay so
I'm like I got to make these work and
it's it's it's like a smooth material in
there is it removable and
washable no okay I foresee a problem
here and so I throw them off on and I
already knew this was true I can't wear
shoes without socks H you get sweaty cuz
my feet sweat and I don't even have this
like super ultra hydrosis of the foot
like I just I'm like a normal foot
sweater there's some people who like
their feet are sweat no matter what I
don't know who I don't know anyone I
mean I see people wearing shoes without
socks I don't I'm so jealous of these
people and I know there's not it's not
it's not that there's no show sock in
there I think they're sweating it's like
there's something about I just I don't
know why but I love the idea of wearing
a shoe without a sock well it's the it's
like the thing that I want more than
anything right now and I I I can't have
it the moment I put my shoe in there why
do you want it so bad the moment I put
my foot into that shoe I was like yeah I
think these shoes are made for that
there's a neoprene liner in there well I
have an answer for you and it relates to
another ad that I want your answer I
want your empathy well don't you want to
wear a shoe without a sock well yeah
because I have a pair of loafers that
are coming in the mail right now isn't a
pair of like leather loafers because and
you're planning on wearing them without
socks well no I was planning on wearing
them with my little no show sucks you're
I know and you're self-conscious about
that yeah but when they don't show I'm
not self-conscious about it I get ads
for I tried to wear the shoe with a noow
sock and you know what it did the noow
sock well no it bunched up it went down
over my heel and it's bunching up all
down in there that's cuz you got a bad
sock and it was the special type that's
not supposed to do that because the sock
like liner of this shoe is so slick that
it sucks the sock it eats the sock off
my heel no matter what do you get the
ads for the cream that keeps you from
sweating and they have it for your hand
hands they have it for your feet and
they have it for your face do you get
those ads no so I probably get the ads
because as you know it's not nearly as
bad as it was when I was I mean in high
middle school and high school and
probably into college like you think my
hands are clamy now oh I know you have
the you had the problem it was I the
reason I I ended up getting that dry saw
you remember that because I was playing
basketball and and I needed to be able
to hold on to a leather basketball and
my hands would get so sweaty
I'm I'm Amazed by the way that back in
the day pre- internet that you
discovered this product and used it on
your hands as we asked the doctor a
doctor told me I didn't like find
information in like the library cuz
right now it's probably an ad on Tik Tok
so there's a new product and I'm not
going to say what it is and you probably
get this ad but like they're doing so
much Internet advertising you know this
there's brands that like the ones that
we've been talking about so far they're
just spending a lot of money on the
internet and actually making good ads
and they've kind of figured out that
game well they've got for your they've
got a deodorant that is like a Super
Hyper effective deodorant but then
they've got creams for your face for
your hands for your feet I don't know
how it works I'm assuming that it
probably has uh it probably does has has
aluminum in it and it like clogs your
pores and eventually stops the sweating
or something I don't know that's why I'm
not mentioning the brand because I don't
know how it works but they make it for
your feet
and if you really really want to wear
something without a sock and you don't
want to wear the no- show sock listen I
got these loers coming and they're so
low that the I got to get a no- show
sock that's just barely holding on to my
foot just like just like grabbing on
both sides of my foot and just holding
on for dear life you know what I mean
yes and then I see the the the people
the cool guys who wear like a
loafer when I say cool guy wearing a
loafer I'm picturing that guy that
paints the cowboy paintings oh I he's my
fashion he's my fashion inspiration I I
love his paintings I don't know what is
does he well he's way cooler than I'll
ever be um Mark he dresses like cowboy
Mark Margot or something like that can
y'all look that up just yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's that's almost it he's like a
I don't think Western paintings I don't
even think he's American he's too cool
to be
American but he's like he's too
good-look to be good at something else
do you know what I'm saying he's too
good looking to be that good of a
painter yeah and that good of a dresser
but he it's really working for him
and um I don't know if I'm saying his
last name right Margot is are y'all
looking it up y we're looking it up Mark
margotti painter Western you'll see a
guy with like a mustache magori
yes I'm trying to find an image of him
yeah it's just yeah I'm I think seen the
guy he's like a mark moror style like
search that and then he comes up and
he's got like um like he dress got a
wind blown kind of a pretty masculine
you know what I'm saying pretty
masculine but he's doing the like yeah
yeah oh see now the ladies have found
hello hello Mark now look at the keep
your eye on the paintings and this guy's
got style for days now he wears a lot of
hats I'm not really doing the Hat thing
but it's you know he's embracing the
sort of like how things have gotten a
little bit bigger and he so he's in like
the pleated pants he'll tuck a butt a
loose fitting button up into pleated
pants but then he's like he's always got
these loafers on and I'm like loafer
should I I mean this is I don't know I'm
just I'm experimenting am I going to do
the loafer thing MH and um so I've got
some coming in the mail not here yet
don't know what's up you thinking you
going to have to buy some sweat sweat
feet but I'll tell you right now I am
100% sure that he doesn't have no show
socks on right a guy that cool that's
what I'm saying but so but something if
you pull it loafer off and smell it what
does it smell like probably smells
wonderful it probably stink you know but
if I did it it would smell like trash
you know what it might smell like the
leather from the loafer maybe that's you
think the loafer you think the leather
the leather overpowers it yeah the the
loafer leather makes your feet smell
better maybe that's the thing his
paintings are cool too by the
way there's
something magical and seemingly
unattainable about just the just the
Carefree nature of sliding your unsed
foot into a shoe right it feels like why
do I have this little teeny sock that
feels like something from the future
like an astronaut would put on before he
got into a suit like why do I have these
it's not just because I don't like the
way it looks when you see my feet it's
that it feels like connection with I'm
cheating a little bit like socks are for
babies shoes are for d ERS I doubt that
this Mark guy wears underwear you know
underwear is a is a modern invention
yeah you know undergarments they used to
just have pants and and you know they
call it Commando you know it's like
right you're in charge it's like when
you don't have underwear on your in
charge it's like I
mean they don't call it
like chafe right yeah you don't
want to be like you know there's guys in
Hollywood who have like a reputation for
like purposely not wearing underwear so
they can just like make you look at
their schlong and their pants you know
things you know well I there's a couple
of guys I do know the Justin thorough
sweatpant there's a thorough thing
there's a torot theory and there's
a Don Draper you know
oh uh what's his
name yeah John Ham John Ham John Ham
John Ham there's there's a theory
there's a theory that Ham's letting it
hang I he's got the Hang ham again I
don't know if it's true I'm just say I'm
not is that is this a slippery slope
like first you're not wearing socks and
you're not wearing underwear I'm just
saying I think the purpose the the best
reason for underwear is that you're
trying not to like give the you don't
want to give you the outline
unnecessarily you know but I'm saying
I'm just saying I don't think that guy
painting
paintings I just don't think he's got
anything he's just got just p shirt
shoes that's it maybe a hat that's all
Mark's wearing he's not wearing
underwear he's not wearing
socks because it's just like I don't
have time for that I've got a paint the
thing that I've done with these shoes is
I've worn them without socks a few times
and my feet have stunk but every time
it's no my feet have sweat but they
haven't stunk yet yet maybe there's
maybe there's a material in there that's
cuz if you maybe I just put powder in
the sock in the shoes I've got powder if
I get some powder odor eaters and then
not a sponsor I'm I think maybe I'll try
that cuz I just want it so bad I don't
and I still don't know why I want have
you dealt with the powder before no okay
well it gets under your toenails and
stuff it's you know you put the powder
in the shoe and then you shake the shoe
and then you look in the shoe and you're
like the powder's gone the powder's not
gone the powder has gotten into the
crevices you put your foot in there and
You Begin sweating initially the powder
absorbs the sweat and then the powder is
like I'm still here right and so like
the next time you put powder in and
definitely the next time you put powder
in now the powder's like we got to go
somewhere and it'll become like a little
ball of powder oh that's got sweat in it
and it's just little nasty little ball
and I think one ball um I think maybe it
might be
multiple cuz I've got a couple of like
down there at the toes cuz I don't have
room at my toes no so like hiking shoes
and uh shoes I've had for many many
years that like I work out in and stuff
like that those are the only ones that I
have to do the powder
in and sometimes I look down there I'm
like I couldn't put my foot into this
shoe without a sock I wouldn't dare
because your sock keeps going in and
grabbing the powder and pulling it out
gives it a way out but if your foot goes
in I just think I just think that's bad
news it's creating some sort of a putty
put putty yeah I think it's creating a
putty e God
mhm and none of this is is is curtailing
my desire you still want it it's so
strong
like maybe I'm maybe I could just have
the foot stink I mean I take a shower
every morning I do scrub my feet
directly yeah and my feet don't sweat
that
much okay well you know what give us an
update I'll let you know when my loafers
come
in okay um
but I wanted to tell you about something
that occurred on my date night with my
wife there's multiple levels to this so
give me a second
okay
um Jesse and I went out to eat on our
date night as we do we checked into the
restaurant we had a reservation that was
made by Sarah um who's been working for
us for a little bit here and
um that comes that'll be key in a second
so we check in and
um the woman checking Us in the
host looks us up and says Ah date
night and I was like okay are we really
giving off like married Vibes this hard
that like you know right Tuesday night
yeah restaurant 700 p.m. reservation we
come in obviously it's date night so I
just chose to take it as a compliment
Yeah Tuesday is also our date night by
the way I think uh you moved a Tuesday
so we could syn our date nights yeah
well again I make a lot of sacrifices I
didn't ask you to move it I think
Tuesday is a superior date
night there it's the least amount of
people at a
restaurant yeah cuay because sometimes
they're not open on mine was Thursday
and I do agree Tuesday is a better day
because when it was Thursday then the
next night you also did something fun
and it was too much fun too much fun
together you got to have early week fun
and it's easier to get a reservation yes
now it feels a little less
happening I'm not interested in that if
you're interested in that um and so we
sit down and it was we you know we we
put our order in and it was like a the
waiter
well the waiter was kind of weird you
know what I'm saying he was acting a
little bit strange saying things a
little bit
unusual but he was also European and so
I was like okay gotta let him have it is
this guy just
European could be uh
or I hate to say this is he a fan that's
that was the next thing I thought
because sometimes okay we've had the
privilege of having enough people yeah
recognize us for what we do that it
isn't uncommon for a waiter or someone
in a kitchen to be a fan and then we
find out and one of the ways I usually
find out is the waiter acts weird for a
certain amount of time yeah and then at
the end of the meal they say by the way
big fan right and I like it when they
just tell me up front because I don't
like to be in this are you weird or are
you a fan and I'm not saying that I
don't say that the wrong way I'm not
saying that mythical beasts are weird I
mean a lot of you are list let be honest
but we are too we embrace it yeah hey
you speak for yourself I'm weird too um
I just spoke for myself and so I just
never know what it is and I also hate to
think this because it is an incredibly
inherently self-absorbed way to navigate
the world is like this person acting
this way because of me and so I don't
even when when that starts happening I'm
like I don't even like thinking this so
I'm just not so I'm going to just assume
he's a European guy you know he's just a
European
Guy and
um he says would you like me to just
bring the stuff out as it's ready or do
you want to do it in a certain order
we're like as it's
ready not interested in the
order and so he he he brings some things
out now we had uh there was you want to
get your main and then get a salad but
obviously stay tuned friend oh no so we
had ordered this side that was a brazed
kale it was sort of like collard greens
like a uh but kale and they can charge
more if they call it that I guess and uh
but we also had an entree like thing
that was a big piece of meat that was
obviously the entree and somewhere in
the middle of the meal they brought uh
some like you know everybody's doing
this pork belly everybody's got a pork
belly course and they brought we didn't
order it and so he sits it down and say
says the pork belly and I was like oh oh
um we didn't order that mhm and he was
like oh I'm sorry and he takes it so
then it bring the entree and the only
thing left is that brace kale we
finished the
entree 20 minutes pass and then I tell
Jesse I'm like they forgot they forgot
about the kale and it's fine because
we're both uh full and also it's kale
you know what I'm saying it says like we
want to we want end this evening on Kale
Hil no so right then he comes up with
nothing and he leans down and Whispers
into my ear yes only and he says don't
worry there's something else
coming
okay then he walked away I'm like again
you must have looked worri at this point
I told Jesse I told him she was like
what did he say I relate it and and she
saidwell he's going to bring the kale
and I said I said it wasn't a kale
whisper he didn't say anything about the
kale he said something else is coming
and he said don't worry right but you
were worried about the kale and so I
told her I said you know when somebody's
Whispering about kale I said he's a fan
or the chef is a fan and they're
bringing something else special don't
worry they're bringing the kale is long
gone yeah okay five minutes past he
comes back with the kale
my
ego cracks takes another
hit and uh but as he sets the kale
down your ego was brazed he leans in
again another whisper and he
says there's something else coming don't
worry this time he didn't say don't
worry he just said there's something
else coming that whisper I gave so then
he leaves and I'm like in reference the
kale I'm telling you see there is
something else coming not the kale he is
a fan mhm I'm first of all I'm on a
roller coaster ride at this point I'm up
I'm down I'm up yeah are you European
and
so then about 10 minutes later he comes
back after you ate the kale oh we ate
the kale how was the kale um kale okay
yeah it was as good as kale can get at
that point in the meal but I knew there
was something else coming so I was
willing eat it cuz it wasn't going to be
the last taste in my mouth the last
taste in my mouth was going to be this
Grand gesture of Sweetness in
appreciation of all the work that I've
put on the internet for all years yeah
right well I was the one there at the
point at that point Where's link and um
he comes back and he sets down a dessert
that you didn't order beignet with some
sauces and there was a candle in one of
the
beignet and then he says happy
anniversary happy anniversary and at
that point I he said the thing I wasn't
prepared for you know I was prepared
for big
fan or something like that I wasn't
prepared for happy anniversary neither
was Jesse and then he walked away before
we could say it's not our anniversary we
actually don't want dessert we're both
kind of full but you know me I'm going
to eat it
so then I like a good beignet Jesse was
like it's a donut that you can charge
more for well here's what Jesse says
Jesse's like we got confused with
another table that is having an
anniversary they also had the pork belly
by the way right and she says we need to
tell them we need to tell them that it's
not our anniversary because anniversary
couple they're not getting anything
right now they got jack don't worry
you're not getting anything we've got
their beignet I've eaten all of them
by the time she finishes making her
point you know I've eat all of them did
you blow out the candle first oh of
course first thing I did it was lit off
and yeah and
so then I'm like maybe we can't no I
said this is their mistake you know
they'll figure it out anniversary couple
will figure it
out and um but then so then we
text Sarah because Jesse was like did
you tell them
something when you made the did you tell
them that it was our anniversary because
she's a little bit of a jokester maybe
she's like oh they'll get something free
if I say this and then she was like I
just told him it was a date
night and I was like oh okay yes you
said it was date night that's why the
woman said date night we weren't giving
off the married Vibes and somehow date
night got turned into anniversary I
think that's my theory um but anyway no
no one was a fan uh he was just
European uh nobody in the back was a fan
no one had any idea who I was they just
thought I was a man on his anniversary
date night and I took full
advantage don't know the lesson that was
a roller coaster that was a an emotional
roller coaster man at least the last
thing you tasted wasn't brazed kale yeah
it it was the really good kale though um
but you always got to say the answer is
always well I want this in is I want
this in the order you know it's like in
the right order well I didn't think it
meant we would bring the side 20 minutes
after the the entree I just thought it
meant we might give you a salad and then
get why on Earth would they even ask do
you want this as it's ready well yeah
cuz I want it to be hot hot but then I
also don't want to eat kale as dessert
because by that if I had to said yes I
would have been waiting 40 minutes for
the entree just for the kale to be done
and then it might would have been cold
or I would have lost interest you
know would you like to hear about
interstates yes I totally
forgot I don't I don't know I was
fascinated you blow my mind about
interstates after all this you now first
of
all you link and you listening you may
already know about this I didn't I never
thought about it and it was a little bit
mind-blowing now I got this information
from a Tik Tok as I get I learn
everything from Tik Tok but it was
really from a I shop on Instagram I
learn on Tik Tok it was um it was really
sort of a Redux of a uh cgp gray video
this is a YouTuber that does these
explainer videos very well researched
funny
informative so you tell me when I say
something you're like I already knew
that or no didn't know that and let's
see how hard I blow your
mind okay okay first things first east
west running interstates I have nothing
to prove and I never do okay all right I
listen that's not what I'm asking east
west running interstates always end in
zero in north south running interstates
Jenna don't don't give Jenna knew
that okay did you know and then north
south are always ending in a
five major interstates North South's
always well I know 95 goes north south
and I know that 40 goes east west okay
so you didn't know either one of these
things no I did not know these things
and did you know that the placement of
these interstates is in a grid across
the United States so as you're going
east as your East West you're stacking
horizontal interstates on top of each
other starting with 10 and then 20 30 40
50 60 70 80 90 and they basically
represent the percentage of the way they
are across the country so 10% across the
country 10 20 now it's not exact huh but
if like 90% away you're up north then
and it they're not exactly to a grid
like that but that's kind of what
they're going for and the same goes 55
25 35 45 55 65 west to east for the vert
IAL interstates not east to west well I
guess that's not how you read it's like
reading so the it's just like a grid
it's it's like well I just have this
predisposition because I always go
towards the West because I'm I started
on the East but it's but no it's just
like it goes up as it goes right and it
goes up as it goes north and the country
was developed east to west so I thought
that as the interstates
were developed they were probably asess
the interstate system didn't come about
until we had gotten all the way to
California I guess not uh it's ay thing
uh what was the president who did it was
it was it FDR I don't know that either
it was about it was basically for the
military it was about the military being
able to get things across so you can
kind of if you're hopping on an
interstate you can kind of know oh if
this is an odd number or is it did you
say fives are odds fives fives and Zer I
there I I'm I've only scratched the
surface my friend but the major
interstates in m5s okay now cuz I know
85 goes down to Atlanta but 95 is goes
down to Florida right so most of them go
all the way across the country so like
40 goes from California to North
Carolina right it goes and I always
thought of it the opposite CU I was
that's where I and then 95 I believe may
go from Maine to Florida they don't all
go all the way to the farthest state and
then there but they but most of them get
almost all the way across the country
they make that track sometimes because
the country isn't this Big Grid they'll
like meet at a city like I think it's
like 75 and 85 like meat at a city okay
you know but uh there's one the only one
I know after 85 that goes
vertical well I know the I know the five
I guess we know the
15 I don't know a 25 30 35 75 goes
through Knoxville Tennessee okay so you
yeah I don't know that one right so 85
this is interesting because 75 and 85
actually cross each other it's a weird
thing so 85 goes from Petersburg V
Virginia to Montgomery Alabama but it
also crosses over 75 and in one case
there is an
Interstate 45 that doesn't even leave
Texas it goes from like two major cities
and it's kind of at a diagonal but I
guess it could continue on forever to
the North if you needed it to but like
huh enough roads go up there where
nobody lives okay like I said I'm only
getting started so far my mind is
being lightly massaged like lightly
poofed it's being poofed like just
breathe heavily up but not
blown I you it's not being Brea it's not
being whispered to don't
worry the reason the reason that was
mind-blowing to me is because it feels
so obvious once it's pointed out and
you're like well of course of course
that's the case it seems like I would it
how have I lived and traveled on all
these interstates I've done the full 95
and I've done the full 40 yeah but
that's actually in the same year I did
both of those and still didn't realize
it well that's because with either one
of those you never encounter another
another one but technically you crossed
all of them you you yeah you wouldn't if
you on 40 you wouldn't have encountered
another horizontal but you you would
have encountered all of the verticals
give or take but you would have not
thought following following a GPS and
you're not thinking about what you're
crossing right but okay again I was just
getting
started those are the majors Interstate
minors are always three
digits okay and these last two digits
match the major right yeah if the first
so in other words like you got 440 you
got 540 in Raleigh right if the first
but those are both circles uhuh no
they're not if the first number is even
it reconnects back to the major so 440
which is often which is a belt line but
it also what connects back if the first
number is f an odd number it's a spur
and it does not reconnect back to the
thing so 540 actually doesn't connect
back to 40 and that makes sense because
540 like goes down to Fuquay or Holly
Springs and doesn't get back to 40 you
know what's actually blowing my mind at
this point the fact that you majored in
civil engineering you took at least one
course which is about nothing but
traffic but it was traffic it wasn't
interstates we didn't talk about this we
didn't talk about intern uh
International we National you did a
whole course on traffic and you didn't
talk about the interstates uh actually
we had to um I think we had to engineer
the 64 bypass as our project but I was
just like oh that's the number no one
talked to us about that right um okay so
those are the
miners but but 540 is eventually going
to be a complete Beltline around Raleigh
no it's not North Carolina so no it's
not I thought that was the plan and then
they're going to have to change the it
to from a five five means it never
connects so there as as is always the
case with everything there are
exceptions to every single thing that
I'm saying so yes there are some evens
that reconnect and I don't know if it
means that if 540 does eventually
connect back to 40 they'll change it to
640 but they might I don't know how it
works that's a lot of signage you got to
update but
technically they plan when they put even
an odd number they are planning for this
to be a spur and to not reconnect okay
but I'm still not
done there of course are duplicates of
these things because all along 40
you've only got nine different ways to
go off of 40 and you've got all these
states you're passing through so there's
going to be multiple
540s throughout the nation
right and uh in some states there's like
cgp talks about this in the video but
like I think Maryland has like every 95
except 995 or something it's like oh you
could have just had it one more and you
would have had it okay
now and Jenna you're you're not
surprised by any of this you're like mhm
she knows she knows
it I'm not I'm my dad um trained me how
to um find my way around without GPS
he'd get me lost on purpose uh when I
was first started learning how to drive
and be like find your way home and this
is such a dad thing to do yes so I I
know all about like that's why 405 you
know 405 is going to come back to the
five at some point like yeah that's why
out here people are so surprised when I
don't have my GPS on when they're in the
car with me like how it's like oh well I
know where I'm going I'm going this way
right and the thing is is that this is
not only somewhat useful in modern times
but this would be end times very useful
in the end times oh if there
H if there's a huge earthquake in LA I
know exactly what I need to do I know
exactly all the roads you know ex to
your dad your dad dad would your dad
just drop you there and then would there
be and then he would leave or would he
just be silent in the car he'd be silent
in the car it was when my brother no it
was when my brother and I um were we had
our learner permits so like we cuz we're
we're twins so my brother would be in
the back seat and I would be driving and
my dad would be in the passenger seat
and he'd just be like all right find a
way home and uh he' just sit there and
would only yell at us if we made like
incorrect choice in like our breaking or
or um accelerating um but he just let us
get lost if we and you didn't know this
that he was going to do this it would be
like at random times it yeah it would be
at random times he he'd say we're going
on an adventure we'll find let's find a
new way home find a different way so so
I'd have to learn different ways you had
to learn to you you learned to be very
Vigilant while you were riding in a car
yeah it's like I mean my kids yeah it's
like oh their brain is off whenever they
got their license of course they just
start you know I had to the most dad
thing I did was teach them where to put
the phone with the GPS on it so that it
wasn't unsafe like I felt like I was
doing my dad ISM at that point that's
the best I could conjure it definitely
helps I um when I went camping once
because I am Vigilant and even if I have
the GPS on going to a new location I
still kind of look around I'm like okay
this is here this is the road blah blah
and I was leaving this Campground once
and none of my none of my stuff was
working zero couldn't couldn't figure it
out and I literally just retraced my
steps and it was like 3 days after I had
done the route and I just literally just
retraced my steps and it took me about
45 minutes to get service back and I
just re yeah I just went back the way I
came that I
remembered um now the one thing I do
know about interstate is that the mile
markers are markers
every mile yeah smart L that's smart
okay last piece of information here so
I've given you the the majors and the
minors right yep there's Interstate
mediums so these are numbers like 64
29 and
those I thought those were just highways
well I didn't say Highway 64 I said I 64
or I29 Interstate you still have to have
the eye still an interstate it still has
the little blue and red with the crown
at the top so I'm not talking about
Highway 64 which is like the black
diamond yeah Interstate 64 Interstate 29
these would be they would fall in
sequence so 29 is going to be
between uh 25 and
35 but because it's a nine it ends in a
nine it's going north south if it ends
in an even just like the majors it's
going to go east west so the M the the
odds and the evens always correspond to
which direction they're going but then
that first number 29 would be the two
okay we know that that's going to be
between 35 25 64 I64 is going to be
between 50 I mean between 60 and 70 but
they reserve it for shorter interstates
yes and there are many duplicates of
these because now so it might be that
like all along this little Corridor in
between uh third like 35 and 25 right
you would have the option for a 29 but
it might be well there's a 29 here and
then you go a few States and there's
another 29 here it doesn't necessarily
mean that they're all going to be
connected connected gotcha and uh these
are according to the to that YouTube
video these are all in the same sequence
except for
99 i99 apparently ends up being I guess
it would be to the west of 95 instead of
the east of 95 because it feels like it
would be almost all the way it would be
like right along the ocean
interestingly
um the highway that is on the the ocean
they call it Highway
one but that's different because it's
not in it's not i1 right in California
but they it was almost like they were
kind of
like it was like a homage to the
numbering system because it was a one
right just found that interesting
because isn't it Highway one yeah but
does it go
interstate um I don't no I don't think
so but interstates don't have to go
interstate they can't be interestate
like the one like 45 in
Texas so anyway man I just blew your
mind yeah I mean you bre you definitely
breezed it you definitely now now that
you when you see
the and the number you can be like there
is a convention is a reason for this
that again isn't always followed but it
there was some intention behind it it's
just not
random H so during the zombie apocalypse
you will be able to like
Traverse you know across the the nation
and know like oh okay we just ran
into 65 let's go left to go north on it
you know it's it's I mean it's
interesting to be to be living breathing
and navigating within something and then
realizing that it it all makes sense on
a on a continental scale well it doesn't
make too much sense but it makes more
sense than nothing it's a lot like the
English language oh there are plenty of
exceptions I'm just saying we did our
best you didn't blow my mind but you
strangely gave me a sense of comfort
okay and that's that's really what I
value so I can go drop you off in the
middle of nowhere and be like find a new
way home
from Kansas
I'm never leaving home without Jenna
I'll just put it yeah just just just
take me on all road trips I know where
to go well it's kind of in the job
description
yeah happy anniversary
guys how many Throwbacks can I make at
the end of this well we need a wreck
from you oh
um my recommendation I totally forgot
what it was what was it at the top of
this
thing talk about shoes you can wear
without
socks uh of course not a sponsor but
this uh I got these flipflops they're
called
arches Australian based company what
you're wearing no okay um they're actual
flipflops they're flipflops that support
your arch in a way that I am addicted to
wearing these I I wear them in the house
they're my house
shoes um because they're good for my
feet and it like it my uh physical
therapist sold me on them because you
know if your if your foot is not
pronating if it's if it's leaning in and
you don't have enough arch support then
it messes up your alignment for
everything at least that's what they say
but I'd warn these things to the point
where they they're virtually
indestructible uh but I wore them so
long and so hard that I finally popped
the flip-flop rest in peace Jimmy
Buffett uh and I I gladly bought another
pair the thong popped yep the thong
popped but um I mean it's been a it's
been a couple of years of literally
wearing these things every day and
they're just they're just really I got
flat feet so they're good for the feet
and there's no there ain't no sweating
in a flip-flop but if you're going to
wear a flip-flop all the time and you're
and you you know you don't want you
don't want to be in your middle-age
planter
fasciitis stage that'll ruin get
yourself some Archies I can vouch for
these
puppies okay well thanks for joining us
for another ear biscuit remember that
you can take part in the conversation
yourself by leaving us a voicemail at
1888 earpod
1 and also you can join the conversation
online with # earbiscuits we always
appreciate that bye for
now I have to say well first of all it's
Ashley from uh sto California and I had
to say that I haven't even gotten to the
important part of the most recent
episode of your biscuits and Link's
talking about his dream about
fighting Rhett and I just love that
they're both like oh it's never
happening it's never happening and then
proceed to immediately get into an
argument about who would win that's
that's uh that's WR link for you thanks
man love you guys to watch more
earbiscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
ear biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best